the president's actions are splitting
the republican party on capitol hill
at least a dozen gop senators are vowing
to challenge
president-elect biden's win on wednesday
citing
baseless conspiracy theories about the
election as nancy cordes reports other
republicans say the move is dangerous
for democracy this is so obviously
beyond the pale is probably not even the
way to describe it
republican adam kinzinger joined legions
of democrats sunday
condemning the president's call to
georgia's secretary of state
it's fundamentally an effort to
overthrow the government of the united
states
the controversy did not appear to deter
the dozen senate republicans
and many more in the house who plan to
contest the electoral college results
in a joint session of congress on
wednesday and we've seen in the last two
months
unprecedented allegations of voter fraud
texas senator ted cruz
is now leading the push for an emergency
10-day audit
of election returns from six states
citing
public mistrust in the results but it's
mistrust
senators themselves have stoked with
baseless claims of fraud
there is voter fraud there is we had one
witness talk about 42 000 people voting
twice in nevada
the the other the other issue
on sunday as members of congress were
sworn in
some republicans tried in vain to talk
their colleagues out of the plan
nebraska's ben sasse this is bad for
that for the country and for the party
maine's susan collins it's time for us
to move on
wyoming's liz cheney the third ranking
house republican
argued the move would set an
exceptionally dangerous precedent
they have us properly distanced but vice
president mike pence blessed the efforts
sunday
he will preside over wednesday's joint
session
which could last all day we're going to
spend a lot of quality time together on
wednesday
i'll be there i'll be there sir
okay we'll get to it in the midst of all
this
california's nancy pelosi narrowly won
her bid for re-election as speaker of
the house in what could be
her last term in the house and this was
a nail biter because
the house majority in the house is now
razor thin for democrats after
november's election she needed 214 votes
there were some defections from
democrats but she managed to pull
together
216 votes gail that's right anthony in
the end she was holding up the gavel
thank you very much